welcome back to a PJ train Design This
is PJ today I would like to show you how
to create this Crown set signal ring
with the Rhino 3D software are you ready
let's get started
alright so for this ring right here I'm
going to start building signal ring and
quickly to build a simple one and I
wanted to show you how to calculate
enough metal for the judicial setting
for this Stone please understand that
this is like when you are finished
setting what it will look like if you're
going to give it to the jeweler you
might want to edit up the high over here
so that you does have some metal to push
over the stone and to finish it and then
after they shape it it will look like
this so keep in mind that the ring is
currently look like when you finish what
the ring should look like on the bench
so that's starting from the scratch
alright so you can download the Stone
from the description below and all you
need to do is the sign up the news later
and I promise I won't send you junk all
right so let's starting with the ring
size I want to set it up for diameter
for 16 and again you can set it up for
any of the ring size for whatever that
you're going to praying currently the
stone is about four millimeter if you
want them to be bigger all you need to
do is coming into the 3D scale and then
you want to snapping vertex to the
vertex so here to here and just type it
the number that you want let's say I
want it to be five millimeter and then
this will be exact five millimeter once
we have it we're gonna starting to draw
the shape of the stone uh first of all
let's go to the top view and I'm going
to draw a circle right there with this
circle it's going to be two Circle one
is how much it's going to cut it in here
so that's the first one and the second
one is I'm going to set it up for about
how thick your prong is going to be so
we are going to get something look like
this all right and ideally as a stone
like if this is a prong or this is any
of the metal so once your stone is now
over 25 percent then you should be safe
all right so then we got those two
circled there I'm going to moving those
two Circle to where I want them to
finish to be so again if this is for the
rendering you want to finish your
progress about half of the table size
which is from this point to this point
all right so half of this size now if
you wanted to be for Judah to set a
stone you do actually want to set them
higher so your children will have enough
to cut it open all right so I'm just
going to put it here right in the middle
for the rendering purpose on this one
okay so once you have those two set it
up we're gonna coming into the front
view and we're gonna draw the rest of it
first of all pattern of the ring shank
or snapping into the zero I'm going to
go from somewhere here to here in order
to make it look nicer I'd also like to
taper the ring shank on the balance just
a little bit so it will look nicer then
we want to connect connect from this
point to the quadrant right here coming
into the curve you have the extended
curve then you're gonna go from The Arc
to the point right so this is the arc
and this is the point all right so that
cauldron is the point so go again from
the arc which is go gonna go from the
Curve
from here and snapping into the quadrant
all right let's take a look on the top
view this is what it looked like right
so I know in on this front view the
profile look like this and this should
be you know the profile for my shank and
then but I don't know how thick that is
though How fat you want it to have right
so I'm going to creating another shape
and this shape simply just using the
ellipse but choose the second ones from
the diameter so I can sniping into this
quadrant here and quadrant here and
decided how thick you wanted to have
right and then the third one is I also
need to have another one right here to
show what's the profile is going to look
like it looks like this is a little bit
too fat here all right so then I'm gonna
go from the top snapping to the quadrant
quadrant you can snapping into here if
you want to it's not necessary but one
thing is you want to snapping right here
with your smile track is on and moving
back a little bit and click on this
point that way you won't get the sharp
edges and that part is quite important
right so now we have this and we can use
the curve Network to create it but now
for the careful Network this is an open
curve this is the open curve but I do
want it to split right there as well so
that one's going to be split with this
one right there so I have one two and
three all right so I have three curve
now once I have an open curve I need
this one to be open curve this one to be
open curve as well so I'm gonna have
that one split by this one and this one
so that I split this way and the circle
as well split by this curve and this
curve so I have a half all right so to
creating the surface we simply just
going to width go with the Curve Network
and we're gonna pick up one two and
three remember to pick in the older all
right and then four and then five and
then you hit enter then you will get
something like this now if you click on
the record history on the bottom you
click OK and if you feel like hey I feel
like I need to have a puffier right and
then so I'm going to moving this one out
the surface will still moving with you
that's the advantage of using the record
history okay so now we have something
like this all I need to do is to mirror
to the other side
like that and then we're gonna
join them
and it will break the history that's
okay because we no longer need to adjust
it and we gonna using the cap command c
a p and we close the one on the top all
right so now this is a solid and I also
want to cut out the ring so I'm gonna
use the X2 planner curve command and to
extrude the ring size and then we just
do the bowling different this one out of
this one all right so voila I have a
ring there all right now a lot of time
it doesn't to be too obviously in my
case right here but sometimes you will
have this bump coming up then you will
need to rebuild it but it seems like
it's not too much problem in our case so
I'm just gonna leave it there now that's
starting planing how we're going to cut
it first of all let's go ahead to
creating a cylinder and this cylinder is
going to be right in the center right
here whatever size it doesn't matter
we're gonna adjust it anyway all right
and now I want to have this cylinder to
cut it in inside all right of course
this is too fast so let's go ahead 1D
scale to be the proper size okay now
coming into my perspective you can see
this is kind of cutting in too big of
the surface and it is parallel to my
construction plane but I want it to be
more in taper right so the way the
quicker way to use a taper make sure
your gumbo is on holding on Ctrl and
shift and click on the surface right
here and we're just gonna do One D scale
it down right there and as you can see
now I have this taper all right we're
gonna keep editing until we find the
proper one but we also need to tilt it a
little bit to give it a little bit like
angle so then once you cut it out it
will look nice all right let's give it a
try come back to the top view we want to
use that one to do the polar array so
snapping into the center I want to type
it zero and I want a six piece for 360
Degree and then we'll get something like
that all right so what are we actually
looking at is actually this space right
here right so the space right here I
want them to be the prong size so you
need to look at it it's too big it is
too small or things like that okay once
we have something that we like and we
can give it a cut and see how does that
look like so we're gonna pick up here
and boiling difference out of here
sometimes if the bowling fail it may
have a seam a line so I'm gonna do it
one more time and just do one by one and
see if if that fail so there's nothing
wrong with the shape it's just sometimes
seems a line maybe sometimes it has two
piece there all right but I do notice
one thing though I do not like this
orientation here so I may want to rotate
them I'm gonna rotate them 30 degree
so I do not have a hole right in the
middle there it's up to you depends on
how you like it but also when you have
something like that notice that this is
like uh cutting into it let me show you
if I bowl indifference this one out of
this one you're going to see a cut there
so the way to fix it is either I'm going
to delete this one either I have this to
rotate it a little bit more and so it
doesn't cut it into it or it just make
them longer alright and once you like it
just go ahead to mirror to the other
side and then we'll get something like
this alright so let's give it a try
we're gonna do bowling difference this
one out of all six of them and then
we'll get something like this all right
the other problem is that what we have
here it doesn't have the hole to go
through it so you can see there's a
weird cut over there under the stone all
the fastest Stone you need to have a
hole to go through so we're gonna have
that piece for the circle that we draw
earlier and then we're gonna extrude
Planet curve straight
something like that and we're gonna
bullying difference this one out of this
one
all right so then if you take a look on
the render view you will see the stone
there's nothing behind it and then you
just need to fill it the edges of the
this opening for what you have and after
you fit it I also fit it inside of a
ring shank then you will get this Crown
set on the signal ring I hope you enjoy
the video I have a lot more chicken tips
to show you on my membership a small
amount of a monthly donation to my
membership is going to help me in the
long run to keep creating the video for
everybody for free thank you for
watching and I'll see you in the Member
Program
[Music]
foreign